I I don't think we crowned Kings in
America you got to work for it and
Donald Trump needs to work for this
nomination
nominee do y'all become friends again
does he offer you a cabinet post again
do y'all clean this up and he becomes
the nominee I don't think so I think
some of the some of the stuff he's
called me
um over the last few months
um I don't think that's gonna happen and
and that's sad but it is the truth of
the matter and it's his doing but you're
not closing the door to voting for him
no I'm saying I can't support him this
is not about glorifying Chris Christie
as the moral whatever Christy stood
behind Trump literally and
metaphorically for years and went with
all of the stuff and now all of a sudden
he's willing to say these things but
still it is a good thing to meet Maga
where they are and many of them are
still watching Fox News